[Musique]
[Rires]
la vie est un tout mais on ne peut juger
un homme qu' après sa mort a dit un jour
François mitteran un an après la mort de
l'ancien président de la République
peut-être est-il encore trop tôt pour
juger et convoquer le grand tribunal de
l'histoire mais ce soir nous allons
tenter un premier bilan en examinant
quatre périodes d'une vie
particulièrement riche et dense la
période de la guerre l'occupation Vichy
et la résistance la période de la 4e
République la guerre d'Algérie les
années 50 la période de la conquête de
la gauche par François mitteran les
années 60 et 70 et bien sûr la période
du pouvoir avec nous quatre observateurs
avisés Jean-Pierre Azema historien un
des meilleurs spécialistes et
connaisseurs de la période de
l'occupation professeur à Science Po
pierre Favier qui a passé 14 ans en tant
que journaliste de la FP à l'Élysée et
qui doncignore rien des secrets de
l'Élysée de mitteran Olivier duamel
professeur de droit constitutionnaliste
spécialiste de l'histoire politique de
la 5è et ses institutions et Jean la
couture qui est spécialiste de tout et
qui prépare un grand livre sur François
mitteran alors comme d'habitude dans
cette émission nous allons regarder des
images d'archives des extraits
d'archives des extraits de discours des
extraits de déclaration et ensuite on
parle première séquence en image
François mittiran et la guerre quand
j'avais 25 ans je me suis évader
d'Allemagne j'aime la
liberté j'ai rejoint le général de
Gaulle à Londres et à Al et j'aime la
liberté je suis revenu dans la France
occupée pour reprendre ma place au
combat j'aime la liberté vous allez
après à Vichi oui et pourquoi alors
qu'il a le gouvernement de capitulation
qui a eu les lois antijuifes vous allez
à Vichi pourquoi vous n'allez pas à
l'ondr la question vous me dites les
lois antijuives il s'agissait des lois
antijuives ce qui ne corrige rien en eff
faet et ne pardonne rien c'était une
législation contre les Juifs étrangers
donc j'ignorais tout quand avez-vous
appris l'existence de ce statut
l'existence des C de concentration
exation pour les camps de concentration
cétait comme tous les Français informés
je ne savais pas grandchose quel est
votre propre jugement sur le régime de
Vichy est-ce qu'il y a des choses qui
sont aujourd'hui pour vous condamnables
et je veux dire irréparable mais
écoutez ça fait combien de fois que je
le
dit la première chose condamnable pour
Vichi c'est d'avoir tiré un trait sur la
République qui était un acte vraiment
intolérable et c'est comme cela que
s'est installé en état de fait non pas
le 1er jour 10 juillet mais le 11
juillet
1940 ça c'était déjà condamnable au
début alors je disais c'était la péouère
c'était dire un vieil homme derrière
lequel s'infiltrait un tas de gens qui
eux avaient depuis longtemps une
idéologie
euh je dirais pas que que pere nen avait
pas hein mais c'était pas un penseur
et les les gens qui se sont infiltrés là
des
gens Moras d'une certaine manière
da autres gens très connus qui ont eu un
sort par la suite on en profité pour
faire une une révolution qu'ils ont
voulu appeler la Révolution nationale et
bien ça c'était détestable alors dans
l'extrait queon a vu au début qui date
de la campagne présidentielle de 1965
François mitteran dit qu' s'est et qu'il
a rejoint le général de Gaulle plus tard
dans quand il a écrit son livre
s'appelleit ma part de vérité 1971 il
écrivait rentrer en France après ma 3è
évasion d'Allemagne je deviens résistant
sans problème donc il a fallu attendre
très tards il faut le dire pratiquement
le livre de Pierre Péant Une jeunesse
française pour savoir
en tout cas connaître le détail sur le
passage à Vichy de François miteran
François miteran arrive après son
évasion à Vichi au début de 1942
Jean-Pierre Azema qu'est-ce que c'est
quel Vichi découvre le jeune mitteran
qui a 25 ans 26 ans quand il arrive à
Vichi au début
19942 disons que il a 25 ans c'est vrai
que c'est un homme comme le plus grand
nombre des Français qui a été
profondément traumatisé par la déroute
par la défaite de 40 qui a été
traumatisé très marqué par son passage
dans les dans les stalagues dans les
camps de prisonniers de guerre dontievad
comme vous l'avez dit donc en décembre
41 et puis alors il devient un V
résistant on peut le caractériser pour
cette période comme un visgisto
résistant c'est-à-dire que dans un
premier temps et son attitude est tout à
fait ambivalente il a été ceci et cela
dans un premier temps il va servir
l'État vichisois mais il sert exactement
en faisant quoi alors à Vichi alors je
vais le dire avant de devenir et c'est
pourquoi il devient résistance il faut
dire les deux avant qu'il ne devienne
donc un le chef nolien d'un mouvement de
résistance à part entière et qu'il
termine en aût 1944 comme l'un des 19
secrétaire généraux euh qui occupe les
ministères de la République en e 44
voilà mais là vous vous la synthèse très
rapide donc on reprend on reprend vooui
on reprend on reprend enfin voilà le
bonhomme en gros début 42 àichi alors
fait quoi alors début 42 il va il va
faire deux choses il va servir l'État
français de deux manières d'abord il
entre comme disons documentaliste voou
la documentation de la Légion française
des combattants c'est un organisme créé
par Vichi en N 1940 qui devait servir un
petit peu de courrois de transmission
d'intermédiaire dans ce régime
autoritaire kevich donc elle rassemble
cette légion les combattants de la
Grande Guerre de 1418 de la campagne de
39 40 elle devait servir aussi de
d'instrument de vecteur de propagande je
vous arrête une seconde parce qu'on va
regarder des images quelques secondes là
de cette légion des combattants de la
Révolution
[Musique]
nationale
les légionnaires prê le SER désormais
traditionnel avant de en r serré 30
journée légionnaire 30 journée française
qui restera dans les anals de Toulouse
comme le témoignage de son attachement à
la Révolution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nationale dans le cadre millénaire des
arènes de cimier 2000 membres du service
d'ordre légionnaire réuni auutour de
François Valentin prononcé après avoir
entendu les fortes paroles de darnan le
serment qu' le fera selon la formule
légionnaire les chevaliers des temps
modernes
agelou je m'engage sur l'honneur à
servir la France et le maréchal Pétin
chef de la
légion à consacré mes forces
à faire triompher la Révolution
nationale et son
idéal suivant les ordres de mes chefs et
la discipline librement acceptée du sol
sol
debout alors si j'ai montrer cet extrait
du du service d' légionnaire des
prestation de serment c'est parce que
Pierre Péant dans son livre cite une
lettre de François mitéran du 22 avril
1942 je cite je comprends davantage les
sol les sols le service d'ordre
légionnaire soigneuse choisi et qu'un
serment fondé sur les mêmes convictions
du cœur lit donc le mitéran d'avril 1942
a l'air d'avoir un certain intérêt
attraction pour ce service d'ordre
légionnaire c'est quoi ce service d'ord
légionnaire mais quand même c'est tout
ça mettre son pétiniste on peut dire si
vous voulez la Légion c'est quand même
pas exactement ça ce service d'ordre
légionnaire c'est une minorité
d'activistes lé au sein de la Légion bon
la Légion là je trouve justement que la
Légion c'est un peu mou et que le sol
c'est quandê oui c'est vrai cette légion
française des combattant ça regroupe à
peu près 1200000 personnes c'est une
donc un organisme de masse extrêmement
difficile dans le fond à utiliser mit
Teran qui dans le fond ve un certain
nombre de résultats comm extrêmement
pragmatique dit dans un premier temps
bon ben je préférerais finalement plutôt
à des molçons je préférerais en gros
donc avoir des gens qui soient qui fasse
un peu d'activité ce qui vous explique
d'ailleurs qu'en ma 1942 il va
démissionner parce que il s ENIT
prodigieusement à la Légion disons de à
la reléigion française des combattants
alors que il a fait ce texte n'a rien à
ajouter mais enfin on ne peut pas dire
que ça soit un ateur de darnan qui est
vraiment lui un musclé vichis musclé qui
va être partisan très rapidement d'une
collaboration qui est un monsie venant
de l'ultraroite on est pas là mais
comment on peut qualifier mitéran de de
ce printemps 42 il est quoi il est
péténiste il est vichiste il est alors
écoutez on va faire on va reprendre le
distingo enfin classique entre
marichaliste et pééniste je crois qu'on
peut le dire maréchal c'est-à-dire que
il fait révérence donc à Philippe Pétin
qui considère comme soit du moindre mal
soit mieux encore comme un monsieur qui
dans les circonstances précises est là à
sa place à la tête de cette France
occupée j'ajoute car ce qui est
important Philippe Pétin qui est plutôt
sec de cœur s'occupe ou veut beaucoup
s'occuper des des prisonniers de guerre
bon et ça ça touche beaucoup François
mitteran qui sera très attaché à essayer
donc d'aider ses camarades qui sont
toujours derrière les barbelet alors il
y a une grande journée paraî-il pour
mteran en anné 42 le 15 octobre 42 il
rencontre PHPP voilà Pierre Péan tout à
fait et euh bon pour lui c'est un grand
jour il le dit et il décrit donc
Philippe Pétin comme un homme oui
nécessaire dans la période qui nous
importe qui peut empêcher un certain
nombre de dérives bref on peut l'appeler
à ce moment-là Marie chaliste je crois
qu'on peut dire aussi péénis parce qu'un
certain nombre de thèmes de la
Révolution nationale cette espèce de
révolution culturelle que Philippe
veut mettre en veut instituer dans cette
France occupée on peut le dire parce
qu'un certain nombre de thèmes lui
plaisent les chefs par exemple bon
c'était banal à l'époque mais enfin il a
fait un certain nombre de d'articles
célébrant la valeur du chef quelque
chose qui marche qui bouge bon et puis
d'autre part on peut l'appeler péniste
parce que il accepte l'un des postulats
de la Révolution
nationale imposé par Philippe Pétin
c'est que on reconstruire la France on
la rénove on fait la Révolution
nationale donc avant avant de se battre
contre l'occupant c'est ce que fait
c'est l'inverse tout à fait de ce que
fait Charles de Gaulle à Jean-Pierre
Elkabach on vient de l'entendre tout à
l'heure il a déclaré d'ailleurs il le
dira aussi dans ses Mémoires
interrompues qu'il ignorait le statut
des Juifs alors est-ce qu'on peut être à
bichi en 1942 et ignorer les mesures de
discrimination contre les Juifs on va
remarquer d'abord qu'il fait une erreur
François mitterence le statut des Juifs
du 3 octobre 1940 fait des Juifs
français h des citoyens de 2e ou de 3e
zone pas et pas les étrangers comm mê
les étrangers c'est le texte du 4
octobre qui permet donc de de les
interner bon c'est même une erreur c'est
même une erreur à la fois je crois grave
parce que quand on est président de la
République et qu'on transmet l'histoire
à ses citoyens c'est une erreur grave et
à certains égards très difficile à
comprendre sauf si l'homme était fatigué
et efftivement était le cas puisque ce
jour-là à ma connaissance l'émission a
failli être annulée une demi-heure avant
compte tenu de de l'état physique dans
lequel il se trouvait en tout cas ce que
disent quelques proches qui étaient à ce
moment c'est très très dommage qu'elle
l'IT pas été franchement alors il faut
quand même préciser que il est
allergique je crois que tout le monde le
dit il est allergique à l'antisémitisme
on ne peut en déceler aucune
manifestation après dans sa vie après
dans sa vie même auparavant même quand
il était un étudiant de
droite militant pour les volontaires
nationaux de François de laaroc des
Croix de Feu il n'y a aucune
manifestation d'antisémitime qui a été
remarqué ni par ses amis ni par ses
ennemis pas sous le pétinisme n'est pas
allergique à l'antisémitisme en 1942 non
il n'est certainement pas allergique si
voulez non je je ne crois pas je ne
crois pas il a certainement dû comme
enfin en servant com Mme il ser l'État
français il a certainement dû savoir ce
qu'était le statut des Juifs simplement
il faut dire si vous voulez que il a dû
comme beaucoup de Français au moins un
certain nombre de Français en tous les
cas comme beaucoup de viois ne pas faire
de ce qu'on appelle la question juive
entre guillemets une question
fondamentale c'est-à-dire que d'ailleurs
la réponse est nette qu'est-ce qu'elle
est qu'est-ce qui vous importe c'est la
République bon les Juifs je veux pas
dire que ça ne prente pas d'intérêt mais
c'est relativement subsidiaire tout de
même faire apparaître darnan en premier
plan là comme vous l'avez fait ne me
paraît pas très correct parce que parce
que la la le vichisme le vichicisme le
maréchalisme de de de François mitteran
n'est pas celui de Joseph darnan
vraiment nous avons vu apparaître là le
côté fasciste du régime Vichi il y avait
un côté aussi bêtement droit
conservateur le côté vieux amiral vieux
général le côté bon le côté l'état Croix
de Feu comme récemment évoqué Jacques
nbécourt dans son livre sur laaroc mais
le fascisme là qui est qui est vraiment
qui apparaît dans ces images
ce le texte de de François miton que
j'ai cité date d'avril 42 ce qu'on a vu
date de février 42 apparten au service
il fallait pas à mon sens il fallait pas
faire para ce qui le fait paraître plus
alors qu'il n'était pas ni fasciste et
en tout cas pas antisémite comme darnan
et comme ses gens je vais faire deuxième
citation je n'ai pas une c'est dans dans
ces mémoires je n'ai pas eu non plus
comme le prétend clarsfeld c'est
l'avocat Serge clarfeld malveillant ou
mal renseigné a signé un papier
certifiant que je n'avais pas
d'ascendant juif bon alors on en vient à
un épisode de euh de l'épisode de la
francisque parce que j'ai là le
formulaire de demande d'attribution de
la Francis qui la première phrase et je
ss signé déclare être français de père
et de mère nêtre pas juif au terme de la
loi du 2 juin 41 c'était quoi cette
francisque elle était donnée à qui alors
la la francisque d'abord c'est un
insigne hein c'est un insigne créé par
une loi d'octob 41
euh alors c'est donc pour récompenser
donc celles et ceux enfin surtout ceux
il faut bien dire euh qui euh militaent
le plus ou qui était distingué par le
Philippe Pétin ou son entourage pour
avoir fait faire des des progrès pour
avoir milité donc pour la Révolution
nationale voilà en gros il y a eu 2800
porteurs de Francisque euh François
mitteran et attendez je je ne dise pas
une bêtisse le
2202e porteur de Francisco alors vous
savez que il a répondu enfin il a dit
assez souvent je l'ai reçu quand j'étais
en Grande-Bretagne ce qui est faux
puisque il l'a reçu très probablement ça
pierre Péant le démontre bien comme il a
fait entre février mars avril et 43 bien
sûr et non pas lorsqu'il était donc à
soit en décembre 43 soit en janvier 44
en tout cas c'était un moment où il
avait déjà commencé des activités de
résistance alors oui alors oui donc on
peut dire comme il l'a souvent affirmé
que c'est une manière de couverture de
couverture voilà cela étant il est resté
encore disons ce début de l'année 43 un
petit peu dans la mouvance d'une
fraction de l'entourage de Philippe
Pétin qui d'une certaine mesuref le
protégeait ou suivait ses activités donc
avec avec une certaine mettons
bienveillance donc je crois qu'il y a
les deux à dire à la fois il accepte et
il le dit d'ailleurs à un certain nombre
de ses amis ça me servir de couverture
en même temps en février mars 43 il n'a
pas totalement rompu toutes les Amares
avec Vich on passe à la pardon on passe
aux activités de résistance à partir de
quand il commence une activité de
résistance quel type de résistance une
résistance contre qui alorsah d'abord la
résistance contre l'Allemand il a
toujours été anti-allemandil a s'il a pu
être attiré par la rolution nationale
toujours toujours bien sûr Antim
allemand et alors il a une sorte disons
ce qu'on appellerait une sorte de SAS
pour passer de cette de de ce de du fait
de servir donc l'état vichissois au fait
de devenir un résistant à part entière
et ça c'est extrêmement important c'est
bien un vichisto résistant ensuite à
partir disons de la fin de l'été 43 il
est véritablement résistant et va de
être contraint de de devenir clandestin
parce que la guestapo la Milice
française va le chercher il a failli
être arrêté plusieurs fois et il a fait
un certain nombre d'actes de résistance
il va donc construire un mouvement de
résistance c'est-à-dire donc à à des
dessins politiques que ayant comme visé
les prisonniers de guerre et ce
mouvement donc va essayer de faire de la
propagande contre bien sûr l'occupant et
essayer de préparer le jour J
c'est-à-dire la libération c'est-à-dire
en mettant sur pied aussi des groupes
francs en commençant un certain nombre
de sabotage il est près de qui de ce
qu'on appelle l'organisation de
résistance de l'armée l'URA qui sont qui
sont fait enfin cet AA est composé
d'officiers en général d'officiers
supérieurs qui ont été vichistes qui ont
servi l'État français et puis qui après
novembre 42 après donc l'opération
torche en en Algérie et au Maroc vont
basculer très brutalement ou
progressivement et entrer en résistance
euh donc ce parcours finalement du de
Vichy à la résistance est assez commun
est assez classique disons pour un
certain nombre de résistants je rappelle
parce que les Français veulent l'oublier
qu'il y a finalement quatre familles ou
quatre sensibilités résistant il y a la
communiste il y a la gaulienne de il y a
j'appellerai la sensibilité ni ni
gaulien
ni ni communiste par exemple Claude
BOURD par exemple Freinet par exemple
Raymond et luci aurac par exemple
Jean-Pierre levvi les mouvements de
résistance de zone sud et et puis il y a
la 4e qui a été longtemps occulté et que
François mitteran pendant longtemps lui
aussi va occulé ce sont ces vichisto
résistants qui ont servi l'État français
et qui ensuite sans esprit de de retour
si vous voulez bascule dans la
résistancement c'est ce qui est le plus
difficile à comprendre aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on puisse être Avichi et en même
temps résistant l'histoire est
extrêmement compliquée une fois de plus
s'agissant de ce ça et de cette
évolution
maema raconte parfaitement et pose
parfaitement on peut dire les dates
c'est c'est autour d'avril à peu près
c'est-à-dire que il passe il passe avril
43 à peu près il y a des déjà des des
rencontres en avril et en mai 43
notamment avril et mai 43 qui sont des
rencontres avec les avec les fractions
communistes avec les fractions Gaulistes
notamment avec Philippe Dechartre en 4
en mai 43 à à la gare de Lyon qui sont
déjà il est déjà un un un résistant il a
déjà une attitude des risques résistant
il commence en février Laura
l'authentifie comme mouvement de
résistance en nous mais il faut bien
préciser que ce ça stat dominante
girodiste et que pendant très longtemps
il va résister aux sirènes gauliennes
avant d'en finir totalement sur cette
période de la guerre un dernier mot sur
René Bousquet parce que les
révélation à la fin de la vie de présent
miteran sur les relations entre Bousquet
et miteran a choqué beaucoup de monde
d'abord qui était en trois mot René
Bousquet pendant la guerre il est devenu
un haut commis de l'État
c'était un monsieur qui fonctionnait
vite et bien dans un premier temps il
est devenu un des plus jeunes préfets de
France il était dans la Marne comme
préfet il a REMARQUE moment défendu les
intérêts français dans la Marne occupée
et puis il va être appelé par laaval il
va accepter d'être le secrétaire général
à la police et alors de là il va être
pris dans un aonage épouvantable et
c'est lui qui est finalement le grand
complice disons euh le grand complice à
l'intérieur du système de Vichy pour
livrer d'abord les Juifs étrangers et
ensuite les Juifs français donc à
l'Allemagne on regarde quelques images
où François mitéran s'exprime sur René
Bousquet quand vous l'avez connu je l'ai
connu je n'en sais rien mais forcément
dans les années 50 c'est-àdire après
qu'il il était on va dire ministre pour
simplifier sous Vichi comme tous les
ministres de Vichi il il est passé en
justice il est resté 5 ans en prison et
il pardon 3 ans entre 45 et 48 il est
revenu là il a été jugé 3 ans 3 ans je
croyais que c'était 5 ans bon et pour
lui mais c'était 3 ans je suis pas
penché sur et 49 il a le procès devant
la Haute Cour il est passé en haut de
cours il a été acquitté une mascarade
disent les historiens non mais dites ça
c haut de cour de justice ça a condamné
beaucoup de gens il se trouve qu'elle
l'a
acquitté c'est pas grâce à moi moi je
suis pas intervenu dans ce procès donc
il y a assez de gens qui sont intervenus
pour dire oui mais oui mais et on lui a
on l'a même relevé de l'indignité
nationale c'est qu'il s'est retrouvé
absolument avec tous ses droits de
citoyens et quelques années plus tard le
Conseil d'État lui a rendu sa lgion
d'honneur et vous jusqu'en 49 vous le
connaissiez pas mais non je connaissais
pas à partir de quand vous ne le voyez
plus je crois que c'est au début de 86
c'est-à-dire quand a commener se
répondre le bruit oui mais le procès 49
ne possédait pas toutes les informations
sur la f du
veldive c'est plus grave que ça son rôle
est plus directement engagé euh moi je
suis pas je n'ai pas à dire c'est vrai
c'est faux mais je suis président de la
République 85 86
et je pense d'ailleurs lui aussi pense
puisquil m'a jamais demandé
rendez-vous nous nous ne sommes plus V
jusqu'à sa mort al une réaction à cette
relation très longue quand même jqu'en
1986 entre François mitteran et Ren
Bousquet d'abord est-ce qu'on peut
ajouter pour qu'il ignorerait que René
Bousquet comme secrétaire général de la
police est celui qui a ajouté les les
enfants juifs au train de déportation ce
qui n'était pas la demande allemande
c'est plutôt laaval quand même c'est
plus laaval que Bousquet alors c'est
Laval et Bousquet Laval d'abord Bousquet
ensuite l'a fait appliquer oui bqu comme
exécutant bon mais on va pas non mais
c'est un point important parce qu'il
faut qu'on sache que l'on parle de
quelqu'un qui a donc qui incarne pour
nous la complicité de l'État français
avec le pire des crimes contre
l'humanité dans la déportation des Juifs
de France fait voà il faut dire cela
pour que ce soit il faut qu'on sache
alors par rapport non sur ce point vous
n'êtes pas d'accord pas de réserve bon
alors par rapport à ça il me semble que
nous avons là le nous avons avec
Bousquet une tâche indélibile sur
mitteran je pense que l'émission du 12
septembre
1984 est un jour noir de la légende
miterandienne et que ce qui est le plus
grave ça n'est pas l'erreur première qui
est l'erreur du pétinisme qui est une
erreur française et courante elle pose
problème pour un responsable politique
ça n'est pas la plus lourde ça n'est
même pas pour moi l'erreur deuxème qui
consiste à continuer de fréquenter
Bousquet c'est une erreur grave aussi et
que de la part d'un responsable
politique mais la pire de toutes c'est
lorsqu'on est président de la République
et qu'on refuse de reconnaître ces
erreurs qu'on disyle un certain nombre
de falsification et qu'on nassume pas sa
responsabilité historique sur des sujets
aussi graves bref qu'on veut justifier
l'injustifiable la vraie tâche elle est
là la deuxème erreur est plus ou moins
adéquate he parce que probablement il ne
savait pas comme comme même assemble de
français que René Bousquet a été donc le
secrétaire général de la police
responsable de la déportation des des
Juifs de France c'est grâce aux travaux
disons de de carfeld que l'on a pu à ce
moment-là voir en 78 pas en 86 oui c'est
ça oui 86 parce que pendant longtemps il
n'a pas su comme d'autres personnalités
de la 4e et de la 5e République et pas
des moindres fréquenter René Bousquet
tout autant que François miter et des
gens qui sont très en vue aujourdhui
dire ça René Bousquet a été un grand
personnage de la 4e République il était
pas ministre il était pas mais il était
vu par tout le monde il compr des très
hautes personnalités juives de la
société française alors bon les gens
auraient dû peut-être s'informer un peu
mieux il a fallu une interview publiée
dans l'Express par Darier de pelpois
pour que pour faire arracher le pour
arracher le masque de Bousquet mais il
avait été jugé par des juges qui en 49
ne badinaent pas tellement avec avec la
résistance et la collaboration n'est-ce
pas il avait été blanchi on lui avait
même après rendu sa légion d'honneur
c'est-à-dire qu'il avait en principe il
avait retrouvé une respectabilité dans
la société française moi je l'ai
rencontré comme directeur de la banque
de l'Indochine pour une enquête pour le
monde en 1951 ou 52 oui oui mais c'est à
la fin des années 70 c'est à la fin des
années 70 que les gens vous évoquez
quand ils apprennent avec l'interview
d'quier de pelepoid et tous les débats
autour C rompent avec Bousquet tandis
que là ça va au je sais que c'est un
sujet extrêmement trouble et douteux et
cetera mais on va pas passer toutes
l'émission dessus les phrases qu'a dit
Olivier duamel sur lé dans la légende de
mitteran c'est un moment noir c'est
incontestable incontestable c'est la
pour moi la chose qui reste quand même
indélébile on arrête là pour la guerre
deème séquence en image la 4e République
mitéran l'homme de la 4e la ville de
Limoge de son côté est fière de
présenter au secrétaire d'État à
l'information Monsieur François mitéran
les délicats chefdœuvres qu'elle doit à
l'art de ses ouvriers porcelainers et de
ses maîtres verriers une double
exposition inauguré par le ministre au
musée de l'vch rassemble les pièces
maîtresses d'une industrie dont le
prestige est
universel Cann a offert aux autes
mondiaux de son festival 1949 Fernand
Gravet et Jean Renoir pénètrent dans le
nouveau Palais du Festival suivi bientôt
par Monsieur mitan ministre de
l'Information et Monsieur four cormeret
directeur de la cinématographie
française
après avoir survolé l'archipel des
commurs monsieur mitan ministre de la
France d're mer a pris pied sur l'île
d'enjouant où il a présenté les
condoléances du gouvernement à la
population éprouvée par le récent
cyclone de l'océan
Indien à tananar Monsieur mitan ministre
de la France d'outrem a présidé une
importante prise d'armes au cours de
laquelle il a remis des décorations à
divers officiers à Monsieur Barg ha
commissaire de France et à une
religieuse qui a consacré à la grande
île toute une vie de
dévouement une gigantesque opération qui
a duré 5 ans va bouleverser la vie
d'Abidjan le percement d'un canal à
travers la bande de terre qui séparaiss
sa lagune de l'océan ouvre soudain à
cette petite ville de la Côte d'Ivoire
l'avenir d'un grand peur africain le
président de l'Assemblée de l'Union
Française et le ministre de la France
d'outrem ont officiellement consacré le
terme de cette imposante réalisation
un caractère de fête nationale a été
donné à cette inauguration qui est une
date importante pour la côte d'ivoir qui
voit s'ouvrir des perspectives
considérables et pour la France qui
donne à l'Afrique noire une nouvelle
preuve de son génie
créateur à Paris monsieur MZ France a
présenté au président de la République
le 20e gouvernement mis sur pied depuis
la libéraation caractéristique réduction
sensible du nombre des portefeuilles et
présence d'homm nouveaux qui fait mentir
ASI que slogan on prend les mêmes et on
recommence heure troublé en Algérie ou
en plusieurs endroits du territoire une
série d'attentats ont été commis dans la
nuit qui précéda la
tousin on parle de faga et de complot
organisés par certaines ligues
musulmanes mais l'Algérie ne se prêtera
pas au rôle souhaité par les agitateurs
on peut croire que le calme sera vite
[Musique]
rétabli en s'attaquant à nos
compatriotes algériens les meurtriers et
les ametiers ont dressé contre eux la
force française cette force défendra la
justice en maintenant l'unité nationale
en protégeant ceux qui travaillent et
ceux qui peinent en rétablissant la paix
civique appuyé sur la volonté de
Concorde et de progrès de l'immense
majorité du peuple elle interdira aux
agitateurs le plus souvent recrutés à
l'étranger la poursuite d'une œuvre de
destruction si les meneurs ont voulu
aller l'opinion internationale à la
veille d'une session des Nations Unies
ils ont eu tort l'Algérie c'est la
France et la France ne reconnaîtra pas
chez elle d'autres autorité que la
sienne nous éviterons tout ce qui
pourrait apparaître comme une sorte
d'état de guerre nous ne voulons pas
mais nous châtirons d'une manière
implacable sans autre souci que celui de
la justice et en la circonstance la
justice exige la rigueur des
responsables et et tous ceux qui seront
surpris agissant d'une façon évidente
par les moyens des armes contre contre
l'ordre doivent savoir que le risque
pour eux est immense dans leur vie dans
leur bien et si nous le regrettons
puisque ce sont nos concitoyens ils sont
soumis comme tout criminel à la loi et
la loi sera appliquée alors Jean la
couture on va venir tout de suite à la
guerre d'Algérie mais auparavant
François mitéran é on soit ministre de
1947 à 1957 est-ce que c'est un
politicien comme les autres ou est-ce
qu'il sort du lot est-ce qu' il a une
image particulière non je crois qu'il
sort du leot vraiment au moment où le
gouvernement de mes France est formé en
1954 et avant on voit là les trois
personnages qui dominent la la
République c'est mè mitterin et
edgarfort il y a trois personnages qui
sont évidemment au-dessus de l'eau qui
comp qui on ils sont en compétition ils
sont ils jouent en première division et
les autres jouent en 2e ou en 3e
division non il est évident qu'il est le
personnage extrêmement
doué par extrêmement
ambitieux très cynique aussi mais qui
est promis au plus grand avenir c'est
évident que il sera après mes et Edgar
fort il sera l'homme l'homme qui vient
n'est-ce pas Olivier duamel vous êtes
constitutionnaliste donc est-ce que il
apparaît quelque part dans les textes de
François mitteran une critique du
fonctionnement de la 4e ou est-ce que
finalement ça lui convient non François
miteran est pas en soi au départ un
partisan de la 4e République il ne la
bote pas et cetera mais c'est pas son
problème principal je je dirais qu' il
est dans un rapport ambivalent avec la
4e République comme sur beaucoup de
choses parce que d'un côté comme vient
de le dire Jean la couture il est un peu
d'exception dans cette période c'est un
esprit libéral c'est un esprit
progressiste c'est un esprit avancé sur
les grandes questions de l'époque on va
y revenir je pense mais d'un autre côté
il est en plein dans le système il est
en plein dans ce que Vincent Riol
appelait le cloac le mar il est dans un
petit il dirige il anime un petit parti
charnière qui s'appelle l'UDSR l'Union
des démocrates et socialistes de la
résistance qui n'est pas du tout uni
assez peu démocrate parce qu' ultra
parlementariste pas du tout socialiste
et avec un rapport complexe comme on l'a
vu avec la résistance et ce parti
charnière et pour tous les gouvernements
parce que ce parti charnière participe
quasiment à tous les gouvernements donc
c'est vraiment à cet égard l'incarnation
du système alors à la fois un homme
meilleur que d'autres plus lucide que
d'autres plus homme d'État que d'autres
et en même temps un homme qui est
intégré dans ce système dont le bilan
est on va pas le faire maintenant mais
contrasté c'est c'est ni l'horreur qu'on
décrit ni une démocratie qui fonctionne
une autre émission sur la qu République
mais Jean la couture on a vu des des
images on voit François miteran en tant
que ministre d'outrem visiter l'Afrique
alors là il a été plutôt un libéral
plutôt un décolonisateur pas plutôt il a
été vraiment un un décolonisateur de
pointe c'est-à-dire que à partir de 1950
quand il est en gouvernement PLV
ministre de de la France d'outrem il est
évidemment il fait presque une sorte de
de révolution les les contacts qu'il
prend à cette époque làà avec oufouette
de boigni qui deviendra après l'Africain
de la République par excellence mais qui
est alors considéré comme un communiste
comme un stalinien on va on fera des
procès à mitéran pour avoir pris contact
avec le stalinien ou fou de boigni qui
était plutôt un progressiste en effet un
réformiste assez audacieux mais quand on
demande à
fouette le Rassemblement démocratique
africain quand mitteran et son directeur
de cabinet Nicolaï les les rencontrent
ils ont des des des des revendications
d'une extrêmement banale c'est qui
relève du du suffrage qui relève de la
justice élémentaire dans les villages
enfin et mitteran et ses collaborateurs
sont stupéfaits d'avoir à à à soutenir
des revendications qui sont celles de
l'humanité la plus élémentaire qui
semble venir notamment par exemple du
discour de Brazzaville du général de
Gaulle c'est ce que demand F c'est
l'application grosso modo de le droit
pour l'homme africain même pas encore à
peine à peine les autonomies encore
c'est plutôt l'homme africain donc sur
ce planlà miteran va prendre la une une
la succession accélérée de du discours
de Brazaville de De Gaulle il est son
successeur en en mettant un point un une
accélération assez forte et parfaitement
justifié étant donné le passage du temps
vers la libération de de de de l'Empire
en tout cas au moins sur le plan
africain et il le fera après sur
l'Afrique du Nord aussi bon justement on
y vient puisquil est on a vu sur les
images ministres de l'intérieur quand
éclate la d'Algérie le 1 novembre 54 il
y a ce célèbre discours qu'on viendrait
entendre l'Algérie c'est la France euh
finalement c'est une position qui est
tout à fait commune et banale à l'époque
quand mittiran arrive ministre de
l'Intérieur chargé des affaires de
l'Algérie en 1954 dans le gouvernement
mades- France il a si on peut dire du
point de vue des des colonialistes un
lourd passé c'est un bradeur il a déjà
il s'est déjà prononcé en faveur des
indépendances des deux pays des deux
anciens protectorats et il a démissionné
après la déposition de sultan du Maroc
donc il est très marqué à ce moment-là
d'où d'une certaine façon sa raideur sur
la sur la question algérienne mais aussi
parce qu'il est le ministre de
l'intérieur d'un gouvernement élu par le
peuple français qui est à ce moment-là à
90 % hostile à quelques à une évolution
audacieuse en Algérie c'est évident que
quand il dit ça il a avec lui une large
partie de la gauche française sans
parler sans parler des milieux
conservateur français il ne peut
rigoureusement pas dire autre chose il
pourrait il pourrait démissionner en
effet il pourrait mais dire il ne le ils
ne le souhaite pas ni d'ailleurs mes
France ce sont des hommes qui en 54 ont
l'impression qui défendent la légalité
qui défendent la nation la question de
la démission si possible va se reposer
plus tard parce que François mittiran et
garde des sauts dans le gouvernement
guimolet qui est de janvier 56 à mai 57
et les garde des sauts et là il accepte
de déléguer l'exercice de la justice en
Algérie au militaire c'est le seul point
je mexcuse le seul point sur lequel au
cour une longue conversation François
miteran acceptait la fin de sa vie de
reconnaître qu'il s'était vraiment
trompé qu'il était qu'on pouvait
l'accuser là le fait d'avoir laissé la
justice au main de la justice militaire
en Algérie ce qui a coûté des vies
humaines il le ressentait comme quelque
chose de coupable il le ressentait comme
quelque chose de coupable c'est c'est et
personnellement moi je c'est un des
points sur lequel aussi je ne je n'ai
pas envie de me réconcilier tout à fait
avec lui sur ce planl nous avons une
capitulation par diverses formes et du
pouvoir politique et d'éléments
essentiels d'un état de droit et que par
rapport à ça vous avez là pour le coup
l'opposition mes France miteran qui n'a
pas de sens avant prend sens ici je
crois là vous avez mes qui démissionne
et miteran qui couvre qui accepte et
donc ça compte sur son rapport avec la
gauche ensuite parce que du coup on lui
reprochera tout cela d'ailleurs on va y
venir parce qu'on va essayer de de voir
maintenant en image comment France
somiterran homme seul a conquis la
gauche dans les années 60 bien qu'il est
trébuché sur les ha de l'Observatoire au
départ survient alors l'affaire de
l'Observatoire en octobre 59 le 16
octobre rentrant chez lui à 1h du matin
miteron se sent suivi par une voiture il
n'a que le temps d'arrêter la sienne de
sauter la grille du jardin de
l'Observatoire
se réfugiait derrière les buissons sa
403 Peugeot est mitraillée de 7 balles
de 9 mm au soir de l'attentat auquel
vous avez échappé grâce à votre sang
froid que pouvez-vous nous
dire ce que j'ai déjà déclaré
à vos collègues de la
presse je ne dirai rien qui puisse
ajouter au désordre des
esprits mais il est logique de penser
que le climat de passion politique créé
par des groupements extrémistes explique
C l'émotion est considérable la gauche
unanime condamne l'attentat mit devient
le héros du jour mais une semaine plus
tard coup de
théâtre dénommé peské ancien député
d'extrême droite déclare à la presse que
cet attentat a été monté de toutes
pièces avec la complicité de
mitéran pour preuve de ce qu'il avance
pesqu montre deux lettres postées avant
l'attentat ouvertes devant huissier qui
décrivent par le menu le déroulement
futur de l'attentat le piège est parfait
miteran a été
[Musique]
berné convoqué chez le juge mitan crie à
la machination il reconnaît que pesqu
l'a bien prévenu de l'imminence d'
attentat il a gardé le silence à la
demande de pesqu pour sauvegarder la vie
de ce dernier les explications de
François mitteran ne convainquent pas
tout le
monde dès le premier jour j'ai dit c'est
une machination et dans le fond
aujourd'hui où je vous en parle rien ne
trouble non pas mon indifférence mais ma
sérénité et s'il advenait qu'on en
reparle j'en serais heureux car je crois
qu'il me serait aisé désormais de faire
la démonstration qu'on me refuse
oui ce dialogue qui commence aujourd'hui
entre nous je l'espérais depuis
longtemps je suis candidat contre le
général de Gaulle et contre lui seul car
lui seul compte à droite hier c'était la
République des députés aujourd'hui c'est
la République d'un seul homme demain il
faut bâtir la République des
citoyens si donc de Gaulle se présente
je le sais
bien les résultats du 5 décembre
deviennent plus difficiles à atteindre
pour les candidats qui se présentent
contre lui vous direz donc mauvaise
nouvelle pour vous bonne nouvelle
mesdames et messieurs cela prouve que le
régime est frappé à mort et moi je peux
attendre l'impression que si le chef de
l'État malgré les atteintes de l'âge
veut encore 7 ans de pouvoir c'est
d'abord parce qu'il ne voit autour de
lui et parmi ses amis personne qui soit
digne d'assumer la fonction et c'est
bien ce qu'il voulait dire l'autre jour
lorsqu'il proclamait moi ou le
néant
pour le second tour des présidentiels
folklore français et pancartes à
l'américaine Monsieur François mitéran a
jeté toutes ses forces dans la
bataille non ce n'est pas vrai vous
n'aurez pas à choisir dimanche entre
leur régime actuel et celui des partis
le régime actuel c'est celui d'un homme
seul et quand viendra pour lui l'heure
de partir il vous livrera au successeur
inconnu que vous désignera un clan une
faction pire qu'un parti cet entourage
syndicat anonyme d'intérêts et
d'intrigue je ne suis pas l'homme d'un
parti je ne suis pas l'homme d'une
coalition de parti je suis le candidat
de toute la gauche de la gauche
généreuse de la gauche fraternelle qui
avant moi qui après moi a été sera la
valeur permanente de notre
peuple un peu plus tard minère intérieur
établissait que Monsieur François
mitteran avait obtenu quelques 100500000
voix et le général de Gaulle
12800000 avec une majorité de 55 % le
président de la République inaugurera le
8 janvier un nouveau septenna violente
ou
Pacifique la révolution c'est d'abord
une
rupture celui qui n'accepte pas la
rupture la méthode ça passe ensuite
celui qui ne consent pas la rupture avec
l'ordre établi politique ça va soir
seconda avec la société
capitaliste celui-là je le dis il ne
peut pas être adhérant du Parti
[Applaudissements]
socialiste vous ne pensiez sans doute
pas négocier toute la nuit quelle a été
la principale difficulté la principale
difficulté que un programme commun de
gouvernement touchant exactement à tous
les domaines de la vie nationale et
internationale cela mérite bien
d'occuper une fois 3h et l'autre fois 6h
et que si on pouvait régler tous les
programmes aussi rapidement on pourrait
estimer que la vie politique naurait pas
à se plaindre François Véran a donc
donné cet après-midi sa réponse à tous
ceux Parti de Gauche et organisation
syndicale qui réclament sa candidature
une réponse formulée au cours d'un
congrès extraordinaire du Parti
socialiste qui l'a investi à l'unanimité
avant de de l'acclamer à son arrivée
quelques instants
après face à
moi-même dont la volonté
être d'être
demain si vous en
décidé portez par vos suffrages d'être
oui je le dis hautement le président de
tous
rendez-vous à bientôt pour longtemps
peut-être alors il n'y a jamais eu de de
suite judiciaire à l'affaire de
l'Observatoire mais politiquement tout
le monde pensait au début des années 60
que François mitéran a été
définitivement plombé mais en 1965 c'est
lui qui va être le candidat de la gauche
de la gauche unie et finalement pourquoi
lui Olivier duamel comment il sort du
paquet par parce que il a tout compris
avant les
autres le vrai problème c'est de savoir
jusqu'à quel point il est en avance il y
a une anecdote qui est racontée par
François Stas dans la morale de
l'histoire comme quoi à la fin mai 1958
à la fin mai 58 il aurait dit au
sous-préfet Pinel dans la nuit en
s'arrêtant entre le verre et Paris Pinel
je vais voter contre de Gaulle on en a
pour 20 ans le seul capable de s'opposer
à lui c'est moi je ferai trois choses je
ramènerai les communistes à 10 %
j'accrocherai une casserole à la droite
et ensuite je gouvernerai au centre bon
là il y a pas encore d'élection direct
du président de la République il y a
déjà chez miteran la perception que
c'est une affaire entre de Gaulle et lui
contre de Gaulle et lui seul dit-il
évidemment avec modification du mode de
scrutin en 62 alors en 62 là myeran
comprend que l'élection présidentiel va
être le levier pour transformer la
gauche et le levier pour le porter lui
au pouvoir comme VG à droite comme
giscar à droite mais c'était plus facile
de comprendre ça à droite qu'à gauche
parce que la droite n'avait pas une
culture vous le savez bien républicaine
antibonapartiste de résistance à
l'élection présidentielle alors que pour
la gauche l'élection présidentielle
c'est une mécanique de coup d'état c'est
un instrument de pouvoir personnel c'est
la gauche a été contre cette réforme du
mode de scrutin
universelle pardon le personnage qui
faisait éventuellement obstacle au
destin national de miterran était pierre
mades France qui était contre l'élection
au suffrage universel donc par ce type
d'élection mitteran voit voit s'ouvrir
le boulevard devant lui et donc il il
comprend ça il comprend qu'avec
l'élection présidentielle c'est comme ça
qui peut arriver au pouvoir et ensuite
une extraordinaire opignatreté pour
parvenir à ses fins on a vu là quelques
dates absolument fondamental la date du
9 septembre
1965 le coup de génie de la candidature
de 1965 il faut savoir qu'à l'époque la
classe politique française ne comprend
rien en à l'élection présidentielle que
personne ne va être candidat on va aller
chercher les uns après les autres on
demande à pine qui dit pas question on
demande à plelin qui dit vous plaisantez
on demande à Maurice fort qui dit quoi
quoi Daniel Mayer Daniel Mayer alors
qu'après sans par Gachon deer
au alors qu'ensuite tout le monde va se
disputer pour être candidat les Français
voient ça tout le temps là personne ne
veut y aller alors miteran a un deuxième
atout c'est que comme il passe pour un
homme de la 4e pour un homme manœuvrier
et tout on se dit à gauche guimolet et
les communistes miteran est moins gênant
que MZ à tout prendre miteran on le
manipulera mieux lourde erreur des
partis de gauche et à partir de là la
deuxème grande date clé c'est celle du
12 juin 1971 quand il prend la conquête
du Parti socialiste quand il veut pas
recommence qu'il a subi en M 68 la mise
à l'écart et qui sait qu'il lui faut une
machine politique et la troisème le 10
mA 1980 c'est-à-dire que c'est une
aventure sur 20 ans pour la conquête du
P pardon on d'ailleurs il avait dit je
me sens porteur d'une patience sans
limite il dit ça dans les dans les
années 58 je pourrais attendre j'ai la
détermination j'ai le temps avec moi et
je tiendrai je le avant avant de venir à
81 est-ce que est-ce que le mitérom
leader du lion de la gauche des années
70 comment on pourrait le le situer
idéologiquement ou politiquement est-ce
qu' c'est une vraie conversion au
socialisme en tout cas ce qui est clair
c'est que c'est le seul dirigeant
politique français qui acceptte
l'alliance avec les communistes et qui
en a fait un le fondement de sa
stratégie dès dès le dès l'origine ça
remonte à très très très longtemps mais
fut si antiommuniste qu'il fut il a
considéré qu'aucune accession au pouvoir
d'un homme de gauche ou sur réclamant de
la gauche ne pouvait se faire sans
l'alliance avec les communistes on l'a
vu tout à fait clairement et ça c'est
absolument fondamental sur le plan de la
stratégie il surclasse tout le monde
c'est vrai que mes France là aussi a
toujours refusé l'alliance avec les
communistes et que c'était s'interdire
l'accession au pouvoir dans ce type de
de constitution et c'est une double
intelligence parce que c'est
l'intelligence de du vecteur de la 5è
République est ce qu'on appelle la
bipolarisation c'estàdire du fait qu'on
ne peut pas faire vivre une troisème
force
entre et c'est l'intelligence du fait
que ça réduira le Parti communiste parce
qu'évidemment aujourd'hui par exemple
pour pour les jeunes qui n'ont pas connu
cette époque et qui seraient pas
historien il faut comprendre qu'à
l'époque le parti fort c'est le parti
communiste et la la composante faible
c'est la gauche non communiste 25 et 20
% et donc il faut un culot inoui pour
penser qu'on va reconstituer une gauche
non communiste et qu'on va réduire
comm alors cette stratégie cette
stratégie est payante puisquelle mène
elle mène au 10 81 l'arrivée au pouvoir
de François mit dans tous les
étatsmajors un peu partout dans t
lesyers on attend ce résultat
effectivement vous l'aurez à l'heure
préc
secondes 5 4 3
2 François mit est élu président de la
République
Messieurs les Présidents mesdames
mesdemoiselles
messieurs en ce jour où je prends
possession de la plus haute
charge je pense à ces millions et ces
millions de femmes et d'hommes
ferm de notre
peuple qui deux siècles durant dans la
paix et la
guerre par le travail et par le sang ont
façonné l'histoire de
France sans y avoir accès
autrement que par de brèves et
glorieuses fractures de notre
société c'est en leur nom d'abord que je
parle fidèle à l'enseignement de
jorè alors que troisème étape d'un long
cheminement après le Front populaire et
la
libération la majorité politique des
Français démocratiquement
exprimé vient de
s'identifier à sa majorité
[Applaudissements]
sociale
[Musique]
la démocratie
assurée l'alternance à joué et ce que
l'on jugeait impossible s réalisé dans
le calme appuyé sur un grand mouvement
populaire issu des prof fondeur de notre
peuple la République a retrouvé son
authenticité et la mutation engagée a
permis d'écarter bien des périls qui
s'annonçaient alors on vient de de
l'entendre à l'instant dès sa première
conférence de presse en septembre 81
François mitteran président de la
République dit l'alternance est jouée
alors olivieramel c'est ça qui va rester
dans l'histoire le fait que finalement
il a réconcilier la gauche et le et le
pouvoir et dans la durée je dirais il a
réconcilié la gauche et le pouvoir et il
a réconcilié la République avec
l'alternance nous n'avions pas en France
de pratique de l'alternance au pouvoir
nous l'avions pas sous la 3e et la 4e
République parce que la République
parlementariste ne s'y prêtait pas parce
qu'elle était comme à l'italienne
jusqu'à peu et nous navions pas sous la
5e République qui avait été gouverné
pendant depuis depuis 1958 par la droite
voilà 23 ans et l' réusé récusé
l'alternance comme ppidou il faut
attendre Valérie
giscardestin même d'ailleurs je partirai
si la gauche gagne au législatif j'irais
à rouiller et il y avait une vision
catastrophiste de l'alternance dans
notre pays il y avait fondamentalement
chez beaucoup de gens à droite la
conviction que c'était
illégitime voir chez certains que les
chars soviétiques seraient à Paris et il
y avait en face chez beaucoup à gauche
l'idée qu'on allait leur faire un coup
d'état à la chilienne on peut pas
imaginer comme était la France il y a
encore quoi 17 ans on peut pas imaginer
à quel point nous pas dans une
civilisation démocratique de ce point de
vue et à cet égard l'arrivée de la
gauche au pouvoir en 1981 le fait que la
gauche soit rester au pouvoir le fait
qu'ensuite sous François mitteran la
droite est pu gouverner puis la gauche
revenir c'est cela l'alternance c'est
pas un seul coup c'est la durée puis les
autres puis l'on revient et là c'est un
transation justement la cohabitation
c'était un bon test aussi du
fonctionnement des institutions regarde
quelques images est ce que dit François
mitteran de la
cohabitation
[Musique]
toujours les doues questions vous voulez
porter des nuances bien entendu il y en
a S quoi
pas mais nous sommes à la et il y a la
France la cohabitation c'est le fait que
deux majorités populaires se sont
successivement exprimé de façon
différente l'une pour le président de la
République que je suis l'autre pour la
majorité parlementaire dont le
gouvernement et l'expression voilà la
réalité elle est donc forcément comme
une sorte de dialectique permanente elle
n'est pas facile à vivre Olivier duamel
est-ce que Françis mitéron se contente
de faire fonctionner C les institutions
ou est-ce qu'il tente de les moderniser
est-ce qu'il les fait bouger un peu non
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle institution
ça dépend si on parle au sens du système
constitutionnel au sens plus large si on
parle au sens plus large il y a des
changements institutionnels très
important il y a la décentralisation qui
est quand même une réforme d'une très
grande ampleur et qui très surprenant
qu'on a pas fait avant et qui quel que
soit ses travers ces défauts étaient
absolument indispensable la France
démocratique voilà et où la France était
reste d'ailleurs à certain égard très en
retard par rapport à des démocraties il
y a toutes les réformes du système
judiciaire l'abolition de la peine de
mort l'abolition des juridictions
d'exception il y a les évolutions sur
l'audiovisuel qui fait que nous cessons
d'être une république semisoviétique à
cet égard là liberté de temps retrouvé
donc il y a il y a des vraies réformes
mais sur la constitution et sur les
institutions alors là au sens étroit sur
not système politique François miteran
ne cherche pas finalement à ajuster à
transformer la 5e République parce qu'il
est assez sceptique sur les questions
constitutionnelles et puis parce que ça
ne lui est pas utile pour son pouvoir il
faut quand même comprendre la motivation
première de cet homme dans ce qu'il a de
plus admirable comme il a dans ce qu'il
a de plus irritant et cette passion pour
le pouvoir et là comme la 5e République
le SERT il n'y touche pas une anecdote
sur ce point sur ce goût du pouvoir de
François mitteran j'ai le souvenir d'un
déjeuner avec avec lui c'était en
juillet 94 sur les bords de la Loire et
quand on lui posait la question on était
quoi de trois comme ça à déjeuner avec
lui en disant mais pourquoi se
représenter en 88 est-ce que c'était
utile est-ce qu'il y avait des réformes
à faire on voit bien que c'est une sorte
d'immobilisme vous ça n'avance plus et n
avez répondu de utilisant cette
métaphore assz extraordinaire en disant
effectivement c'est le goût du pouvoir
nous sommes nous à ce niveau-là de
l'État comme le les gens qui ont le goût
du jeu il ne joue plus pour gagner de
l'argent c'est simplement le plaisir de
jouer le bonheur d'être là autour de la
table de jeu bah le pouvoir c'est un
petit peu cette drogue on est là on a le
goût du pouvoir et quand on l' on peut
plus s'en passer on va le voir ce que
vous venez de dire en image parce que le
on voit qu' c'estz bien il enfile les
les habits du monarque
[Musique]
républicain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ence
pierrev on vient de voir des images du
1989 les fameuses cérémonie du
bicentenaire on a l'impression quand
même que François mitéran ce rituel ses
fa s pompes la République il aimait bien
non oui il était très attaché à tout ça
dans dans son esprit il en parlait
souvent il se voyait comme inscrit dans
la lignée des rois de France il
suffisait de passer quelques quelques
moment avec lui régulièrement et il ne
s'empêchait pas de vous énumérer la
liste et la lignée de tous les rois de
France qu'il connaissait par cœur il
s'inscrivait tout à fait dans dans cette
lignée et il y avait une une deuxième
raison je crois ce comportement ce goût
pour le protocole et pour le le rituel
de la République il pensait que c'était
une façon encore de légitimer la gauche
au pouvoir la gauche avait été à l'écart
du pouvoir pendant 23 ou 23 ans
effectivement il pensait que s'inscrire
et
se revenir au modèle du général de
Gaulle c'était une façon de donner ses
les droits à la gauche de gouverner elle
avait la légitimité et je me souviens
qu'au début de 81 quand il arrive pour
s'installer à l'Élysée la question se
pose de savoir dans quel bureau il va
s'installer est-ce qu'il va s'installer
dans le bureau de son prédécesseur
Giscard desestin qui n'était pas dans le
bureau du général de Gaulle mais dans le
dans le bureau du directeur de cabinet
de Gaulle est-ce qu'il allait retrouver
François mitéran le bureau de De Gaulle
ou est-ce qu'il allait changer tout à
fait de niveau même aller au
rez-chaussée plutôt qu'au premier étage
et là la seule réponse qui donne à tous
ces collaborateurs où était installé le
général de Gaulle et on le dit le
général de Gaulle était là donc
mettez-moi dans la pièce du général de
Gaulle et plusieurs fois lorsque les
gens du protocole l'interrogent au cours
de ces deux SEP comment faut-il faire
est-ce qu'on doit pratiquer comme ceci
ou comme cela à chaque fois il disait ne
regardez pas ce que faisait jisc ce que
faisait Pompidou que faisait le général
de Gaulle et faisons de la même façon et
à chaque fois c'était la référence en
tout cas pour donner la dignité à la
fonction et à la République dans la
couture on a vu des images là des des
grands travaux laisser sa marque dans la
pierre c'est manière de laisser sa
marque dans l'histoire oui bien entendu
oui c'est la pierre c'est quand même ce
qui tient ce qui tient le plus longtemps
pour autant qu'on sache n'est-ce pas oui
non non je crois qu'il a attaché
beaucoup une importance capitale aux
constructions soit qu'elle soit à mon
avis parfaitement réussi comme le Grand
Louvre soit qu'elle le soit moins comme
la grande bibliothèque ou ou ou ou ou
l'Opéra Bastille mais enfin c'est vrai
que pour lui c'est un c'est fondamental
et c'est là où on trouve la la tradition
monarchique qui est tout à fait
fondamentale et là d'ailleurs moi je
m'étonne beaucoup ayant travaillé pas
mal sur le général de Gaulle que le
général de Gaulle en ce domaine n n n eu
souci que de conserver et pas d'ajouter
au patrimoine national grand comme
peut-être considér que lui-même était un
monument d'une dimension telle qui
n'avait pas besoin d'en ajouter d'autres
pour François mitteran un chef de l'État
devait être un bâtisseur c'était ça
Louis XIV avait laissé Versailles il
voulait laisser sa trace la pierre le
verre et cetera et donc pour lui c'était
effectivement très très important et les
arbres alors Françis mitteran arrive en
1981 avec le slogan changer la vie il va
être le président de la justice sociale
de la lutte contre les inégalités et
contre le chômage on regarde en
image en quelques semaines beaucoup a
été fait faut-il rappeler la majorité
tion du SMIC l'augmentation du minimum
vieillesse des allocations familiales et
de l'allocation logement le vote d'une
loi d'amnistie large et généreuse la
suppression de la cour de sreté de
l'État l'abrogation de la peine de mort
la loi de
décentralisation le rétablissement des
libertés universitaires le prix du livre
les nationalisations adoptées hier pour
doter notre pays d'un système de crédit
apte à encourager l'initiative et d'un
app industriel capable d'entraîner
l'ensemble des entreprises dans la
révolution technologique de la fin de ce
siècle un plan pour l'emploi et le Fran
défendu j'en
passe certes beaucoup reste à
faire j'en ai le moyen le temps ni la
volonté ne me manqueront pour la mise en
œuvre de mes
engagements le chômage et l'inflation
touche durement beaucoup des nôtres et
c'est Contrex le chômage l'inflation que
le gouvernement a engager l'essentiel de
son action pour gagner la bataille de
l'emploi j'attends de tous les Français
qu'ils mobilisent leur faculté d'énergie
d'initiative et d'entreprise et
j'attends du gouvernement qu'il leur en
donne les moyens en tout cas la reprise
est
là c'est la première réponse à nos
efforts
communs il y a chez nous beaucoup plus
d'exclus et de laisser pour compte qu'on
ne le croit
généralement que ce soit pour cause de
chômage de maladie
d'ignorance de pauvreté que sais-je mes
chers
compatriotes
1993 s'en va et le aura été l'année
noire du chômage qui ronge nos sociétés
occidentales depuis bientôt 20 ans qui
frappe chez nous plus de 3 millions de
familles qui interdit à la jeunesse
d'espérer qui pose aux responsables du
pays à tous les niveaux et dans tous les
secteurs la plus grave question de cette
fin de siècle alors il y a eu les
réformes du début du premier septenat
qui on été mise en œuvre par Pierre
morroy mais quand même la question se
pose où est passé l'ambition sociale la
société française est plus inégalitaire
en 1995 qu'en 1981
oui il reste l'échec premier de la
gauche qui est pas que l'échec de
François mitteran qui est l'échec de
toute la gauche et qui est l'échec
social bon alors alors qu'elle avait le
temps de gouverner pour une fois
oparavant elle l'a eu peu mais cette par
les intions de la 5e République elle
avait le temps devant elle temps qui se
pose que la France n'est pas seule dans
dans cette dans cet environnement
économique mondial et qui doit prendre
en compte il s'en rendre compte
peut-être un petit peu trop tard dans
les années 82 83 au moment de de ce
retournement mais ils prennent en compte
l'environnement économique européen et
mondial et et le choix là se pose de
façon décisive en 83 de choisir ou
l'Europe ou au contraire une France qui
s'isole et qui ferme ses frontières mais
il reste une part de responsabilité pour
des pour des politiques et pour des
politiques de gauche une double part de
responsabilité d'une part parce que le
chômage chez nous est pire que dans la
plupart des autres pays développés
comparables donc il y a au moins cette
part de pire là cette
incapacité à faire aussi bien ou mieux
que les autres ou à faire moins pire que
ce que l'on fait et puis la deuxième
c'est de faire croire qu'on va faire
reculer le chômage et ça c'est une
erreur qui n'est pas propre qu'à la
gauche mais qui va peser lourd dans la
déconvenue et dans le désenchantement
oui d'accord et de ne pas dire surtout
qu'on avait changé de politique à partir
de 83 on continue à dire ça n'est qu'une
parenthèse on continue la même politique
et on ne veut surtout pas assumer le
changement de cas politique je la
couture faire quand même une comparaison
historique indispensable avec le Front
populaire le Front populaire la partie
gauche du Front populaire parti a duré 7
mois au bout de 7 mois c'est la pause là
elle a duré le double à peu près pendant
à peu près 14 mois le gouvernement de
gauche fait une politique de gauche
politique de réforme en profondeur et
que le peuple français soit le plus
conservateur du monde ou pas en tout cas
pendant 14 mois la gauche fait ses tient
ses promesses elle tient ses promesses
fait une polique AC il a pendant 14 mois
alors que Bloom don le caractère de
gauche ne peut pas être mis en question
et qui était soutenu euh dans pour
l'essentiel par le Parti communiste sans
participation mais avec soutien ça a
tenu 7 mois à une époque où la France
était une grande puissance où elle
dépendait beaucoup moins des autres
c'est-à-dire qu'en 82 83 se fait le
choix en effet entre le socialisme ou
l'Europe continuer sur la voie
socialiste et enfermer la France dans sa
voix originale socialiste l'exception
française ou bien participer à l'ffire
européen mit est évidemment plus plus
européen que socialiste c'est bien clair
et il fait pencher la balance du côté de
l'Europe contre le socialisme un dernier
aspect de si on veut faire un bilan
c'est ce qu'on a appelé les les affaires
est-ce qu'il y a eu un déficit moral
autour de au cours de ce double septonat
on regarde en image une affaire
l'affaire péchiné et ce que François
mitteran dit à son propos Roger Patrice
pela l'un des tout premiers noms côté
français à avoir été cité dans l'affaire
péchiné mi-décembre le journal l'Express
révèle que Patrice a acheté 10000
actions de la société triangle un achat
exécuté à Paris en son propre nom mais
voilà dans une période critique quelques
jours avant la transaction officielle
entre Péchin et les Américains un sacré
coût financier mais hier nouvelle
révélation du journal Le Monde Patrice
pela aurait en fait acheté non pas 10000
mais 50000 actions après un deuxème
achat beaucoup plus discret en Suisse
Patrice pela se retrouve donc ce soir
sous les projecteurs car également très
proche du président de la République je
considère que l'argent gagné trop
facilement est toujours suspect et qu'en
effet il est fait pour corrompre et je
préfère puisque l'argent il en faut
c'est un moyen d'échanges nécessaires
dans une société moderne je dis que il
faut absolument que cet argent soit
orienté vers les investissements qui
servent notre pays parce qu'ils servent
notre économie et qu'il faut prendre
tous les moyens qui conviendront pour
éviter l'argent ulatif si on vous a
critiqué dans cette affaire s'il y avait
matière à vous critiquer si les
journalistes cri' critiqué d'avoir un
ami qui est compromis dans cette affaire
si on vous a critiqué aussi c'est c'est
d'avoir dit souvent de rappeler souvent
le le rôle moral de la gauche et on vous
dit aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez plus
parce que il y a un certain afférisme
rose parce qu'il y a des un afférisme
rose quoi qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
vous vous ne serait pas embarrassé non
plus de rappeler le rôle moral de la
gauche et notamment vous vienez de le
faire dans les affaires d'argent
aucunement car je compte bien que la
sévérité devra se montrer à chaque
occasion et vous pouvez compter sur moi
pour cela j'estime que rien ne doit
intervenir qui empêche l'action de la
justice pour qu'on en finisse avec ces
mœurs Olivier duamel ou Jean la couture
ou les deux est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
y a une responsabilité morale du
François mitéran dans ces affaires oui
bien sûr comment dire non il était il
est le patron il a assez voulu il a
assez voulu le pouvoir le plus pouvoir
possible dans les limites de la
Constitution oui bien entendu ce qui
sort de de visqueux et de et de les
sanis qui sortent du du du du pouvoir il
en est naturellement il en a trouve une
part de responsabilité c'est évident
oui sa responsabilité aura été surtout
d'avoir laissé faire de dire la droite a
toujours fait pire et et de les de
laisser faire et de vouloir ignorer en
fait ce qui se passait dans dans ce
domaine
là les images parlent d'elles-même tout
le monde le com est même nécessaire ici
rien à ajouter cela dit rien n'a changé
sous le soleil on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui on retourbe dans les
mêmes on fera une autre émiss sur la
suite et pour l'instant on reste à
François mitan à tous les quatre
puisquon arrive au terme de cette
émission on a vu beaucoup de d'extrait
d'épisode de la vie de François mittiran
je vrais demander pour vous quelle est
la cohérence dans cette démarche les Lig
de force dans dans cette vie quelles
sont les valeurs qui la fondent enfin où
est-ce qu'on peut tracer une ligne de
continuité
je crois qu'il a poursuivi enfin on peut
lui donner au moins trois points sur
lequels il a il a rarement il a rarement
varié le premier point je crois que il
est
amarxiste et il le demeurit de bout en
bout le le second point c'est que il a
toujours été a ou antigolien et le
troisième point c'est qu'il a toujours
été pratiquement
proeopéen on dit qu'il a souvent varié
que il était une une sorte de maiavel
qu'il était enfin que c'était un
florentin de vie politique mais au moins
ces trois pointsl me semblent avoir été
trois colonnes vertébrales de son enfin
trois colonnes vertébrales trois piliers
au moins de sa trajectoire oui je crois
que effectivement c'est le bilan l'homme
de l'Europe mitéran l'Européen qui qui
restera s'il a eu un engagement c'est
bien celui-là depuis les landemain de la
guerre même si au début de sa début de
son prer SEP en 81 l'engagement européen
n'était pas la priorité puisque l'Europe
incarne pour tous les gens de gauch le
PS et les communistes c'était l'Europe
libérale l'Europe du capital de marché
et il ne se comment dire il se convertir
réement l'Europe qu'à partir du tournant
de de 83 mais effectivement ce qui
restera c'est mitérant l'Européen et je
crois aussi un homme de liberté celui
qui a libéré les ondes et qui était
profondément pour les libertés qui a
supprimé les tribunaux d'exception
autant de choses qui étaient importantes
et qu'il fallait faire Oliv duamel bilan
d'une vie il veut l'Europe il a raison
il aime le pouvoir trop et il est
ambivalent et regardez comme aujourd'hui
il y a très peu de gens qui l'aiment 100
% et il y a très peu de gens qui
détestent 100 % beaucoup moins
qu'autrefois Jacques Chirac lui rend
hommage Lionel Jospin le critique
finalement François mitteran nous oblige
à la nuance et en ce sens il nous
civilise la couture
c'est le démocrate absolu parce que il
nous aura représenté de la façon la plus
min la plus multiple sur ce visage il y
a vraiment 50 ans d'histoire de France
où nous aurons tous un petit morceau de
la peau de mitéran c'est un petit
morceau de nous-même alors il y a
évidemment une beaucoup beaucoup de
livres sur François mitteran je vais
citer ceux qui ont servi pour préparer
cette émission pour que les
téléspectateurs puissent poursuivre un
peu cette discussion évidemment François
mitéran mémoires interrompu publié chez
ODIL
Jacob le livre de Pierre Péant Une
jeunesse française sur faard absolument
indispensable excellent livre c'est bien
Jean-Pierre azemal dit c'est très très
bon donc paru chez Fayard pour tout
connaître demi-teran 3447 pierre Favier
et Michel Martin Rolland la décennie
mitéran c'est le tome 3 paru au Seuil
Olivier duamel c'est pas
directementtiran enfin c'est le
fonctionnement de la 5e République le
pouvoir politique en France pour aux ESS
Jean-Pierre azemma je signale parce que
vous êtes là que vous avez préfacé les
archives de guerre qui sont les tout
recueil l'index plutôt annuaire de tous
les Arch AR chiv filmé qui existe Alina
pour ceux qui ont envie de faire des
films c'est assez passionnant je signale
le livre de Alain duamel portrait d'un
artiste excellent livre paru qui paraît
ces jour-ci chez
flamarion à tout senir tout honneur
franç mitéran ma part de vérité oui
c'est le premier essai d'autobiographie
qu'il fait au début des années 70 sur la
politique étrangère de François mitteran
Hubert Vedrine les MRE de François
mitteran à l'Élysée 81 95 défense et
illustration de la politique extérieure
de François mitéran excellent livre paru
chez Fayard il y en a encore Catherine
ne c'est ancien mais c'est toujours
utile noir et le rouge l'histoire d'
ambition paru chez Grassé c'est le
premier livre un peu à décaper cherche à
décaper oui voilà décapant qui est paru
chez François mititeran qui a écorné un
peu la statue et enfin France Olivier
Gisbert France mitérant une vie paru au
Seuil voilà merci à tous les quatre la
prochaine émission des brûs de
l'histoire dans à peu près un mois sera
consacré à la bataille d'Alger merci
[Musique]
bonsoir